good morning John there are some days
when I know like exactly what my job is
and some days when I definitely don't
and like It's Not Unusual to finish
cancer treatment and then take a little
step back and be like what is this what
am I doing is this my life that's also
not that unusual when you turn 43 and I
turned 43 the day before I got diagnosed
with cancer so like this is new and I
don't love it side note if you found
yourself thinking over the last few
months Boy Hank shirt has talk about his
cancer a lot yeah just imagine what it's
like inside my head anyway we've done a
lot of different things on this YouTube
channel there was a fairly long period
of time when we were trying to figure
out whether or not our docon pooped in
our Nintendo when we were children we've
also tried through a number of high
impact strategies to reduce the barriers
to higher education in America those are
two pretty different things we don't
have like a shortage of things we're
trying to do like last week I announced
that during chemo I had very
meticulously designed eight pairs of
socks delightfully patterned socks that
I spent a whole lot of time trying to
make perfect and now we're selling them
so that more people in the world can
have access to cancer treatment cuz let
me tell you having access to cancer
treatment is great it's so good also
just FYI if you do not live in the US
and you want to get these socks or
anything from good do store or the
amazing complex Le calendars or indeed
anything from dftba.com or ma merch.com
or the Dropout TV store this is the last
day for a standard shipping order to be
guaranteed by Christmas so like maybe
after this video you want to go shopping
even if you are in the US you might as
well cuz it's not like you don't have
people that you'd like to buy gifts for
also for people in the US today and
tomorrow you get free shipping on any
order over $50 at dftba.com and we sell
for a ton of amazing creators so trust
me it's not hard to find $50 of stuff to
buy but that's not what this video is
about because even after all this time I
feel like this is all so new like all of
this stuff that we're that people are
doing on the internet that there are
lots of ways to do things that people
literally just haven't thought of yet
which brings me to another thing that I
did while I was getting chemotherapy I
kind of like impulse bought a piece of a
mobile game now if I had impulse bought
a mobile game on the App Store that
would not be weird that's not what I did
I saw this amazing Gameplay trailer on
Tik Tok and I reached out to the
developers and I got Early Access and I
played it and I loved it and it was so
delightful and then I got on the phone
with the developers and they told me
that publishing a mobile game is really
difficult and fraught and they were
really close to the finish line but it
was really hard and I said y' I love
your game how about I buy 10% of it
you'll get some money so that you can
make sure the game is perfect before
launch and then I will get 10% of the
game's Revenue forever and I'll donate
that to the foundation to decrease World
size and so everyone I own a piece of
gobbin I was told to not make any
significant serious decisions while I
was going through chemo I don't get a
new car you're not in your right mind
but I did pay I don't know around the
price of a new car 4 10% of a mobile
game and yeah some people did try to
talk me out of it but look I wanted to
be alive so everybody download gobbins
cuz look I don't regret this it's kind
of amazing basically nerd Feria has a
game that's ours now like we not all
ours but it's some hours and it's a
great game and we didn't have to develop
it we had extremely talented artists and
developers that did that and they'd
already almost finished it when I came
along it's so fun and 10% of whatever
money it makes is going to go into the
money that we distribute as part of the
project for awesome and it gets better
if you could believe that cuz you have a
chance to actually add to the game how's
that work gobbin is a word game and when
you make a word and then clear it it'll
pop up with a nice little message
congratulating you but sometimes those
messages are different they're little
Easter eggs for example if you put in
Obi it will say you're our only hope
there are hundreds of these override
words that's what they call them at the
studio so three things if you could do
this for me one download gobbin it's a
free game there aren't even any ads you
only get to play once per day unless you
pay six bucks I suggest you pay the six
bucks it's a lot of fun you get like
cool in-game prizes when you play but
you can also buy in-game prizes they're
not necessary to play the game though
they're just fun things two when you
finish playing you can make a postcard
here are some of the postcards they're
amazing if you post the postcards people
will see the postcards and they'll be
like what's that from and you could tell
them or you can just use hashtag gbin
people will see it more and more and
they be like I need to play this game
and that will be good for us and third
in the description I have put a form
where you can add a suggestion for
override words basically you just submit
the word and the message that pops up
when you get that word obviously humans
will curate this list so know that we'll
be looking at them before they get put
in the game we're not going to pick
everything but it is going to make the
list of override words much longer like
maybe instead of hundreds of words it
will be thousands of words but you have
to do it in the next week I'll be taking
the form down after that gobbin is on
IOS and Android it's the number two word
game in the app store right now it's the
number 14 free game in the app store
right now which is amazing I mean
honestly why don't we just do this
together right now do you have your
phone it's probably nearby my phone is
right here here's my phone open up the
app store did you open I'm not joking
around have you opened the App Store now
you're going to type in the search bar
in the App Store you're going to type in
gubb and it's going to autofill to Gin
and or the Google Play Store on Android
that's also a thing you can do after the
advertisement because it wants me to
download toun Blast which I'm not going
to do I'm going to go click on Goin and
I'm going to download gobbin which I've
already done did you do it did you do
it did you do it it's a lot of fun and
the entire project is a thing that
definitely to me in this moment of a
little bit of existential anxiety and
confusion is my job like I have other
jobs but that doing something like that
that's my job and that's a pretty dang
good job John I'll see you on Tuesday
also everyone in the description there
are links to the various stores where if
you are not in the US you have only
today for standard shipping with
guaranteed delivery by Christmas
including various good dot store holiday
boxes which are anywhere from $25 to $99
you probably know this but all products
on good. store donate 100% of their
profit to help make the world a better
more Equitable place and we are already
running out of some Styles and sizes of
the cancer socks so if you want to get
those there's no time like the present